salut à tous c'est pêcheurs de trésors
aujourd'hui on s'est arrêté sous un
petit pont qui est très sympa c'était
pas prévu mais ça va être pas mal quand
elle est là ainsi que rasta allez là
j'ai quelque chose
si je l'ai pas perdu
ah oui
une pile allez ça commence à des
pollutions
1er lancer une pile ça fait plaisir
parce que ce pont n'a l'air de n'avoir
jamais été fait
donc ça voudra bonjour vous connaissez
c'est des aimants
il y a plein de choses
oh non
moi aussi en même temps
ah non
couper
je sais pas ce qu'il en est de toi
voilà je vais venir ouais
bien coincé comme il faut mais on peut
reprendre la pêche j'ai donné une
cuillère de pêche au pêcheur qui était
en haut du pont
et on va voir ce qu'on trouve d'autre
ici sous ce pont
ouais une pince
regarde
presque tous les coups je pense que ça a
jamais été fait ici
en fait on le sent au poids quand on a
quelque chose accroché on le senté puis
d'un coup on sent le tic et après c'est
le dessus plus lourd
[Applaudissements]
il y a du poil
alors
[Musique]
on a une fourchette
bonne balade merci vous aussi
sur Internet maison de la détection ça
s'appelle oh elle est pleine
[Rires]
0423 elle est bonne
ouais ouais ouais ouais ouais ouais
ouais ouais ouais ouais ouais
alors ça c'est la première fois que ça
nous arrive
très anciens
ah ouais
Nokia je sais pas le modèle si vous
savez 33 c'est lancé
tiens
le portable c'est cool ça
a été filmé
j'ai quelque chose c'est sûr
c'est bizarre
drôle de forme encore
petite 5 centimes d'euros
ça fait toujours plaisir
[Musique]
allez devine l'année
non elle a tournage
et oui une 99 c'est les premières c'est
ça
alors quant à mon frère ça a lâché
tu es pas content
alors moi je vais trouver quelque chose
puisque le grand frère ne fait plus le
travail rasta c'est quoi cette position
là regarde le
[Musique]
mais il est couché sur le muret là où il
y a qu'une patte
j'ai mal entendu peut-être mais j'ai cru
comprendre on a le droit à une bière
peut-être que c'est un petit peu pour
eux que
on va l'entendre tout de suite en fait
parce que
c'est pas la chaîne d'un bateau
[Rires]
velsen velsen en tout cas bien sympa
bien ça passe cette petite réaction là
ça c'est une scène qui va devenir culte
je pense
avec le sursaut de tout le monde alors
là c'était vraiment tout au fond
vraiment tout au milieu du pont donc
c'est très bon signe
et un certain poids
c'est une échelle un truc comme ça
on va là je me suis mis sur le pont donc
on va voir ce qu'on peut attraper d'ici
normalement il y a une plus grosse
surface là j'ai quelque chose
ok rien d'intéressant c'est assez lourd
oh oui bobine de cuivre
ok sympa
toujours cool de faire un peu de cuivre
je crois que c'est bon pour
c'est bon pour ce côté du pont et je
pense pas qu'on fasse l'autre on a un
petit peu pressé par le temps on va
changer d'endroit on roule toujours très
doucement sur les ponts et
voilà celui-là nous a dit quelque chose
on s'est arrêté on a fait quelques
travails originales donc ça valait le
coup c'était bien sympa on va goûter la
bière on va vous faire la séance de
dégustation
alors on a péché cette bière sans alcool
je vous rappelle
dans les bières
on va essayer d'ouvrir avec cette pince
pêcher sans alcool aussi et pêcher et
pêcher
comme dirait les fumeurs il faut bien
mourir de quelque chose nous on va
mourir en buvant cette bière et en
attrapant le café
en tout cas à l'odeur elle a l'air bien
de la force
super fraîche
blague mais ça reste de la saison
il y a une date non normalement
bien sympa encore une fois très joli
très joli endroit très calme on va voir
ce qu'il y a parce que c'est une route
qui est quand même bien passante
j'ai jeté là j'ai senti plusieurs choses
on va voir c'est le premier lancer donc
qu'est-ce qu'on a
ok ok donc on a une pince
alors celle là je peux vous dire qu'elle
a vécu
et ensuite ça on reste sur de la
ferraille classique
les gants ça suffit pas toujours pour
les hameçons
elle me paraissait énorme cette pelle
mais vraiment mais c'est peut-être parce
que tout le reste
non mais en termes de taille
ah oui ah oui ah ouais ouais ça c'est
une vraie pelle mais bon elle est
totalement mangée oui regarde par
rapport à ma tête quand même ouais c'est
vrai c'est de la pelle
voilà mais là elle est foutue
comme le pont d'avant
une pièce surtout elle est grosse
c'est du franc
c'est du franc et du franc et du frein
hop dans la poche on se rend maintenant
au troisième spot de cette vidéo où on a
rejoint Maeva une abonnée allez vas-y
premier lancer premier lancer de la
bonnet
facile facile et normalement si tu sens
un truc
bon signe un bois
ça compte
tu peux le sortir
tu es content de ta Troyes
pour l'instant meilleur 3D de la journée
comme ça
tu peux trouver la vie qu'il y avait
avec maintenant
on a déjà fait des soutiens-gorge comme
ça
moi j'ai un truc
morceau de poteau électrique
ou 50 mais là c'est bizarre ce qu'il y a
au mieux
ça glisse dessus
[Musique]
ouais j'ai filmé bien joué
on met la bonne musique là
c'est quoi morceau de scooter je crois
morceau de cadre de scooter alors bien
joué Samsung
c'est pas un Wiko
bien joué
sympa
tu devrais trouver des clés de voiture
c'est comme les iPhone bon tu viens
m'aider je suis bloqué là
ça suffit pas ça pour une journée non
dommage ça lâcher ah oui voilà pour la
petite pièce de 5 centimes tout propre
oh non
c'est pas le poisson c'est la ferraille
tout ce qui est magnifique
des vélos
c'est notre chaîne YouTube
ouais des fois il y a des choses sympas
mais là on a fait un portable
il y a des armes des coffres-forts
des grenades un peu comme votre t-shirt
des fois
et du coup
ouais on va essayer ouais ouais
c'est dingue
c'est incroyable donc là j'ai trouvé une
corde on va voir ce qu'il y a au bout oh
non c'est pour les poissons ça non
je crois que c'est pour garder les
poissons dans l'eau ça
a le droit de l'essayer
américaine
super
oui oui oui ok
ça va être la partie d'un très ancien
moteur quelque chose dans le genre si
vous avez une idée en commentaire
ah oui une boule de pétanque
franchement elle est en bon état
ouais
dedans non vide oh il y a une pièce en
plus
c'est un demi franc
ouais
de l'année 1966
pas mal
rata
allez
c'est bien allez va là-bas
c'est bien
ah ça fait une pièce une pièce une pièce
oui
j'ai deviné les neuves
italienne 1977
elle est trop belle magnifique
de base
pour les abonnés qui nous regardent en
mangeant
tu viens de la pêcher
par contre c'est petite
[Musique]
ah punaise mais oui exactement
c'est ça
on a même le téléphone si vous voulez
vous abonner à sa page
elle est toujours dehors
pas mal de trucs une trouvaille une
trouvaille
ça va mieux
bon ben voilà on a fini ce pont et là
c'est un pêcheur qui nous a dit qu'il y
avait déjà 10 pêcheurs allemands qui
étaient là il y a quelques jours une
armée de pêcheurs donc arrêtez de faire
comme nous c'est réservé aux
professionnels
en vrai ça fait plaisir c'est de plus en
plus propre c'est cool mais voilà
quelques belles trouvailles quand même
le petit portable bien intéressant des
pièces moi je suis content de ma pièce
italienne
productif hein c'était vachement
intéressant ouais franchement juste le
fait de sentir que tu as pêcher quelque
chose à savoir ce qu'il y a dessous etc
c'est super intéressant prochaine fois
si tu es dispo on ira à Toulouse là
normalement je suis là
c'est important très important pour la
pêche pas de souci allez à la semaine
prochaine